it has two parts to it one is having
poverty and the other as a connected
goal is having hunger and is it
realistic theoretically yes but in many
countries are way off track at this
stage many countries particularly in
Africa are way off track and if we're
now have more than halfway through that
period the goal was set in 2000 the
target is 2015 and if we are to have a
chance of achieving that there needs to
be a much greater urgency and indeed
more resources and it's getting going to
be get become more difficult to get
those resources in the current economic
climate so it goes back to the point I
made earlier that the resources we have
at our disposal the development
community and let's put it that way
those resources are going to have to
reuse very intelligent and very
strategically and the partnership that
is implicit in achieving those goals
between countries themselves the
ownership of their development process
and the other development actors the
donors the NGOs and so on that those
partnerships have to really work because
if they do work then you can do a lot
more with the resources a job